apple just announced the brand new mac  studio with the new m1 ultra chip and  there are actually things that they did  not mention  if you're getting an m1 max in a mac  studio it could actually perform better  than the same chip in the macbook pro  and the highest and 64 core graphics and  when ultra might not have perfect  scaling compared to the 48 core version  meaning that you're paying a lot more  money but not seeing you know a linear  increase in performance and we saw that  with the m1 max in the macbooks even  though apple advertised those high-end  configurations most people don't need  them when you're spending that extra  thousand bucks you're only getting some  extra graphic scores you don't get any  more bandwidth any extra encoders or  decoders ports none of that the last one  apple is now giving us apple care that  is a yearly subscription that doesn't  just expire after two or three years  this can be running indefinitely